comme président et chef de guerre cette
détermination
désukrainiens la force des Ukrainiens
Zelinski l'incarne peut-être aux yeux du
monde en tout cas il en parle dans ce
prochain extrait
alors si on change un peu notre approche
on se rappelle que churchilla a connu
son heure la puissance est-ce que vous
l'aurez déjà connu parce que vous vit
dans une forteresse votre vie est
vraiment très limitée et vos concitoyens
vos concitoyens meurent à tous les jours
comment vous continuez comment
faites-vous
je ne me laisse pas
m'habituer à cela savez-vous on peut
s'habituer à la guerre on peut
s'habituer au nombre de décès on peut
s'habituer sur le plan émotif ah oui des
morts ici c'est la guerre quand même
après tout mais pour ma part
je vis avec l'idée que je ne suis pas
prêt à m'habituer à notre souffrance à
m'habituer à la guerre à m'habituer
à ne pas ressentir de la douleur de
toutes ces personnes
tuées et donc j'ai besoin de l'énergie
pour que cela me motive à tous les jours
à chaque matin pour avancer vers la
victoire par conséquent
je veux demeurer
à mon humanité un humain bien ordinaire
quelle que soit
cet état de président mais je parle aux
gens je sors un peu je conduis-nous tout
là où c'est possible on s'entend bien
sûr tout cela c'est plutôt limité on est
d'accord en lien avec la sécurité de la
personne mais je parle aux journalistes
voyez-vous
je dois m'en tenir à la réalité je
n'aime pas entendre
me faire raconter la réalité de source
tierce je veux la voir de première main
je peux être présent sur les médias
sociaux de toute façon il est important
pour moi d'être bien informé papa
parfois je veux juste me détendre le
soir après une journée de travail c'est
intéressant pour moi de voir comment le
monde évolue ailleurs sur la planète je
veux demeurer bien vivant comme être
humain pas seulement sur le plan
physique parce que le président de la
Russie et peut-être vivant sur le plan
physique mais on a des doutes sur le
reste
on a beaucoup parlé de la détermination
ukrainienne pensez-vous que les gens
auront plus peur avec toutes ces
attaques de drones et que les gens
pourront peut-être moins être en mesure
de vivre leur vie quotidienne l'eau de
vie les gens sont vivants ils sont en
ville les gens sont différents entre eux
les gens ont tous peur de mourir
personne ne veut perdre un être cher
personne ne veut perdre une maison
une maison qui vous a pris toute une vie
d'économie et là mais c'est la rive et
vous perdez soit proche parent ou
quelque chose qui vous est précieux et
cela a perdu à tout jamais donc à cet
égard
tous les gens sont vivants parce qu'ils
vivent ses émotions c'est ça leur
humanité même les gens forts ont des
côtés faibles des faiblesses et c'est
tout à fait normal
mais l'Ukraine n'est pas un mon trajet
non on est uni
l'Ukraine est assez forte et sa réaction
à cette agression d'un état immense qui
est entré chez nous
est évidente et on est peut-être pas
puissant sur le plan historique on le
comprend bien on met en face ce n'est
pas une grande Russie pas du tout notre
vis-à-vis n'est pas ce qu'il était mais
c'est sûr il y a des moments où ça fait
peur
je vous l'avoue volontiers
on n'a pas le choix savez-vous c'est
quoi notre choix on n'a pas d'autre
endroit où aller c'est notre seul pays
notre seule terre et donc
c'est compliqué pour le monde entier que
ce conflit et pour nous aussi
mais assurément on va jusqu'au bout
merci beaucoup
merci bien ressenti
on lui a souhaité bonne chance si on
avait besoin Tamara qu'est-ce qui fait
la force deux élanski mais il est
soutenu par les Ukrainiens d'où vient
cette motivation qui est peut-être une
arme redoutable contre la Russie comme
je dis c'est un excellent communicateur
c'est un gars qui vient pas de la classe
politique donc ici comment parler aux
gens aux jeunes mais ça ça veut pas dire
qu'en temps de guerre et pendant la
souffrance on devient quelqu'un qui est
capable de d'unir son peuple il a réussi
à le faire je pense que ça présence il y
a toute une stratégie de communication
même les entrevues qui donnent comme ça
au Canada ça fait des mois qu'on a
demandé à cette entrevue là du côté
canadien ça fait partie d'une grande
stratégie pour pour continuer même si
bon on parle du côté humain de la guerre
c'est toujours pour continuer la
pression sur l'Occident c'est toujours
un thème qui revient pour continuer à
soutenir
l'Ukraine et moi j'étais en Ukraine et
puis je me rappelle j'ai eu des
conversations avec des gens qui n'aiment
pas particulièrement mais qui ose pas le
critiquer et qui me le disait on ne peut
pas se permettre mais c'est intéressant
avant la guerre sont toutes popularité
avec chuté on lui reprochait de
maintenir la corruption ou même niveau
qu'il avait promis des éliminer je veux
dire il y avait plein de problèmes
et c'est sûr qu'il a réussi à rassembler
son peuple et ça c'est et comme il le
dit pour rester humain tout le monde a
peur de mourir en Ukraine c'est pas une
exagération qui dit lui qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez donc Dominique parce que
moi je pense que très fort évidemment
c'est la révélation
d'humour en Russie devient il parle
couramment le Russe même si
bien maternelle il vient de créer
non mais au-delà évidemment c'est un
communicateur exceptionnel toute son
équipe mais aussi c'est que lui-même et
les Ukrainiens se présentent pas comme
des victimes depuis le début j'avais des
invités là à la conférence à Ottawa
trois trois jeunes dames avec mes
étudiants et puis le message de toujours
la résistance on résiste on résiste pas
il faut se plaindre on est avec les
Russes en ce moment et puis ça vient
d'en haut c'est absolument donc il se
reconnaissent dans un ski je pense dans
ce sens-là
de se plaindre puisse beaucoup de force
dans les messages mais je pense dans
l'ambiance générale il vit dans la
réalité de son pays la réalité
coupéman qui avait été qui avait été
libéré il était le 24 heures plus tard
alors qu'on bombardait encore à 10 km
seulement donc je pense qu'il y a une
question de courage sur le peuple en
général on utilise beaucoup le mot
résilience c'est sûr qu'il y en a mais
je pense qu'elle vient d'une instinct de
survie
et surtout maintenant parce que vivre
dans les villes du front on peut les
fuir si on en a les moyens c'est une
chose vivre avec ces drones supposément
iranien et puis on en a de plus en plus
la preuve qui passe comme ça à la nuit
puis qui pourrait tomber n'importe où
n'importe comment sans être intercepté
c'est c'est
une un nouveau niveau de terreur et puis
les gens nous disent c'est notre survie
donc se lever le matin et continuer à
vivre malgré tout ça c'est l'instinctif
et une de ces missions de ces défis
c'est de d'éviter que s'installe une
lassitude au niveau international il
doit tenir non seulement les Ukrainiens
mais tout l'Occident ensemble pour
arriver à vaincre possible dans un sens
le pacte c'est que c'est les Ukrainiens
qui se battent pour le temps le temps
pour le temps donc c'est pour l'Occident
donc vous pourrez dire pour le monde
dans la mesure aussi le chantage de
l'ordre international à l'heure hier
soir les armes c'est les Ukrainiens qui
se battent donc ça place les Ukrainiens
dans une position de force qui ont
jamais eu
on prend en fait on pourrait dire
qu'actuellement l'armée ukrainienne est
probablement la deuxième plus grande
armée de l'Otan en termes d'expérience
de combat les Américains sont toujours
dans une classe à part alors si jamais
il y avait un membership là il devenait
membre de l'OTAN il serait pas un
surtrat entre là et bon il sera au
devant de l'accélérer
en conflit peut pas peut pas adhérer à
le temps il y a aussi sexy
une nouvelle guerre mais là le temps va
aller se battre pour l'uken c'est pas le
pacte actuel le modèle me semble le plus
bon peut-être le temps à long terme
Israël puis une espèce de forteresse là
ultra armé donc il serait l'armé par les
Américains
l'Ukraine armée par les Américains là on
parle d'une sortie de guerre là contre
une Russie qui bon voilà qui sera
défaites et qui c'est qui pour arriver
plus tôt que qu'une crème protégée
carrément par les soldats de l'OTAN
c'est ça
de Poutine en tout cas où la mort de
poussière moi j'ai parlé à un ami très
cher en Russie qui à qui j'ai demandé
bon j'ai pris des nouvelles et il me
disait c'est peu important si je
soutiens Poutine ou pas parce qu'il
était un grand supporteur de Poutine il
dit on est dans le même bateau qui coule
donc il se sentiment là en Russie même
si des gens qui le cheval je parle du
petit peuple je parle pas de l'élite
mais quand même mieux ce sentiment comme
si être heureux c'était une condamnation
quelconque mais on sent que son pouvoir
s'effrite c'est un témoignage parmi tant
d'autres mais sans dit non en terminant
quelques secondes
la mobilisation la mobilisation
partielle les drones etc je pense que
c'est un signe de désespoir de la part
des Russes aussi et les zilenski le
premier était tout le peuple plus
craignant mais très conscient ils sont
convaincus qu'ils vont gagner la guerre
mais aussi désespéré c'est aussi une
Russie plus dangereuse
merci de nous avoir accompagner pour
bien écouter
volodium pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI